in the opening scene we are introduced
to a man named Aaron who is standing on
the rooftop of a building with a
cigarette in his hand he appears to be
extremely frustrated and Restless he
tries to contact his wife but does not
receive any response from her it turns
out that she is already dead in her
apartment Aaron then leaves a voicemail
expressing his frustration he repeatedly
says we could have done it together soon
after he gets overwhelmed by his anxiety
and commits the unthinkable clearly they
did not do it together in the next scene
we meet Liv a young woman living with
her boyfriend Hamming she is currently
in the middle of a conversation with her
mother who urges her to come back home
as soon as possible after hanging up the
call Liv starts packing her belongings
and is on the verge of leaving a few
moments later Hamming wakes up and
inquires about the matter Liv says that
she's fed up with him as he is always
busy with work hemming tries to reassure
her but their conversation takes a dark
turn when he reveals that one of his
clients committed them thinkable just
because he took a work break in order to
spend time with her it turns out that
he's talking about Aaron feeling that
Hamming prioritizes work over their
relationship Liv feels disheartened and
storms off we also learned that a
mysterious virus is affecting people
worldwide leading to severe mental
disturbances and instability some
experts claim that the virus induces a
phenomenon known as involution
essentially causing individuals to
regress it means the people are
eventually turning back into primitive
states of mankind according to a
professor the human species are losing
their frontal parietal lobes which are
responsible for associative and analytic
Behavior due to this human emotions are
being affected and the symptoms are
heightened irritability quick temper
aggression shouting slurs and fortnite
lobbies and so on in order to provide
support to such people the government
has created an online platform called
the companion system several staff are
recruited to handle the clients via
companion system and Hamming is one of
them he currently feels very guilty over
Aaron's tragic demise as he was
responsible for taking care of him what
makes this even more heart-wrenching for
Hamming is the fact that Aaron was his
first client Hamming should probably be
fired the scene then shifts to 100 days
prior where we see hemming talking with
Aaron through Aaron's voice it is clear
that he is frustrated but Hamming
somehow manages to persuade him to take
his medication timely and calm down
shortly after the session Hamming is
scheduled to conduct another one with a
client named Kane sardo as soon as the
session begins Kane starts to vent his
frustration confessing that he threw
away his medicines he even admits that
he killed someone in the street who is
blocking his way in addition to this
Kane passes some mean remarks towards
Hamming and tells him that his therapy
sessions aren't helping him at all
regardless Hamming tries to console him
but the client refuses to listen and
leaves the session abruptly probably to
go kill again Hamming should definitely
be fired a few days passed by and Kane's
mental state continues to deteriorate on
a particular day while in the midst of a
bath he receives a visit from his friend
named Ian Kane initially addresses him
in an aggressive manner but his behavior
shifts to the light upon learning that
Ian has brought with him some narcotics
wasting no time Kane consumes these
drugs which provides him with a sense of
momentary satisfaction however they are
interrupted by a knock at the door and
to their Terror popo come it's the
police in a state of panic the two
friends managed to evade the apartment
just before the police break in later on
Kane believes that Hamming is the one
responsible for alerting the authorities
however he knows nothing about Hamming
due to which he is unable to locate him
80 days ago from the present day Liv
became one of hamming's clients via the
companion system over time their
therapeutic sessions eventually turned
into a close bond of friendship one day
the two decide to meet in person which
was against the rules of the companion
system in this way their connection
blossomed into a room relationship
however their love has now started to
suffer marked by constant arguments that
hurt each other's feelings back in the
present Liv reaches her home but she is
unable to unlock the door with her
fingerprint after several failed
attempts she resorts to her signature
and eventually gains access upon
entering she is welcomed by her mother
and her new boyfriend later while having
some food Liv's mother shares her
intention to sell the house she now
wants to relocate to a better place with
her partner Liv vehemently opposes this
decision as the house holds the memories
of her late biological father hence she
refuses to sign any documents but
unbeknownst to live her earlier
signature on the entrance Door allows
them to proceed without her consent when
Liv gets to know of this she gets so
angry that she grabs a fork and stabs
her mom's boyfriend stepdads are never
cool she's just getting a head start on
the other hand Hammond continues his
attempt to call Lyft but he is unable to
reach her concerned he contacts the the
police to reporter is missing only to
learn that they can initiate the
investigation only after five days from
the moment the person went missing left
with no other choice Hamming takes
matters into his own hands he uses her
companion system identification number
to trace her location and Ventures
towards the same sadly his long absence
from using cab services has led to his
membership accounts expiration God this
view of the future is freaking me out as
a result of this Hamming has no other
choice but to walk on his way he
approaches a random guy and requests for
a ride to the subway station believing
that he is some kind of Thug the guy
pulls his gun on Hamming prompting him
to retreat in haste after several hours
of walking Hamming arrives at the subway
station where he stumbles upon an
injured man lying on the ground
concerned he approaches the guy and
proceeds to call 9-1-1 for medical
assistance however Hamming is
unexpectedly attacked by an unknown
assailant from behind knocking him out a
short while later he regains his
Consciousness only to this discovered
that the injured man is stolen all of
his belongings including his backpack
identification cards and even his shoes
despite this setback Hamming manages to
get back on his feet and Boards a subway
train to continue his journey in the
next scene we see Kane venting his
aggression by beating up a person
coincidentally the person happens to be
the same guy who robbed Hamming cane and
Ian inspect hamming's backpack and come
across his identification card Kane
immediately recognizes him and becomes
Overjoyed at having found his Target
they also access hamming's device and
determine where he is heading to without
any delay the duo rushes to the subway
station but they narrowly missed the
departing Train by a few seconds this
infuriates Kane so he berates Ian
blaming him for being too slow upon
learning that the next train won't
arrive for another 25 minutes they
devise an alternative plan they steal a
car from a woman and speed away on their
way Ian questions whether he is sure
that hemming was the one who alerted the
police response Kane asserts that it
must be either Hamming or Ian himself
meanwhile Hamming falls asleep on the
train and dreams of himself being
stranded in a desolate landscape as he
approaches a mysterious entity in the
middle of the land he abruptly snaps out
from the dream after getting off the
train Hamming resumes the rest of his
journey on foot he makes several
attempts to hitchhike but to no avail
while walking along the highway he comes
across a group of local gangsters
robbing an innocent woman however this
time Hamming chooses not to get involved
in it so he swiftly moves away from the
scene on the other hand Kane and Ian
find a young girl seated in the back
seat of the car she happens to be the
daughter of the same woman whose car
they've stolen this freaks Kane out but
Ian manages to maintain his composure
and begins talking to the child they
introduce themselves though Kane insists
that Ian should not reveal their true
identities when the latter disagrees
they get into a heated argument and end
up crashing the car are you kidding me
fortunately all of them survive with my
minor injuries Kane drags himself out of
the crash vehicle but Ian takes a moment
to choke the girl to death okay making
it appear as an accidental death
following this chilling act the two of
them continue their Journey on foot
elsewhere Hamming finally reaches his
destination and knocks on one of the
house doors within the community an old
lady answers the door and Hamming
inquires about Liv's residence in
response the old lady directs him
towards the house near the woods later
on this elderly woman retrieves some
food from the kitchen and enters a room
where she is tied up a young girl in
Chains she throws the food to the
captive girl Gretel who devours it the
young girl behaves unusually presumably
because she is also affected by the
mysterious virus a short time later
Hamming arrives at Liv's residence and
finds the door open he walks into the
house only to witness the lifeless body
of Liv's mother and her boyfriend lying
on the floor terrified he feels uneasy
and collapses on the ground in this
subconscious state he experiences a
nightmarish Vision where Liv is
mercilessly feeding upon his flesh the
following morning Hamming wakes up
overcome by Shivers he proceeds to get
some food from the refrigerator and digs
into it appearing as if he has been
hungry for days his behavior indicates
that the virus is slowly overcoming him
as well amidst this he hears someone
entering the house and as a result he
quickly hides himself behind a couch The
Intruders turn out to be none other than
Kane and Ian who were there in search of
Hamming Cain proceeds to search the
entire house while Ian begins to play
with a rope in the swimming pool after a
while Kane gradually approaches the
couch but Hamming somehow manages to
crawl away and hide beneath the kitchen
sink shortly after Kane walks into the
kitchen but he is unable to stand the
rotten smell from the dead bodies
prompting him to leave in the next scene
Heming walks out and Ventures towards
the woods in search of Liv after a while
he finally locates her but she is
already infected by the virus Liv is
behaving in a primal Manner and feeding
on Raw flesh Hamming slowly approaches
her and manages to soothe her agitated
State he says he'll just change his name
to hammer and they can be cannibals
together he then takes out his jacket
and covers her body with it in the midst
of this he also reminisces about the
joyful moments they shared in the past
not long after Kane and Ian spot the
couple and launched an immediate attack
on them Kane goes after Hamming whereas
Ian uses the Rope to drag live by her
neck during the commotion Hammond grabs
a stone and Strikes it hard on Kane's
head he then positions himself above
Kane and delivers a series of forceful
blows ultimately killing him following
this salmon quickly rushes to Liv's
rescue seeing him Ian makes the Escape
but by that time Liv is no longer alive
this heartbreaking loss shatters Hamming
prompting him to break down in tears
with great sorrow he carries live to an
open field where he lays down beside her
he holds your hand and eventually
breathes his last breath as the time
lapses the remains of the couple
gradually decomposes transforming into
skeletal remains subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching